hello hey Annabel scaredy ah god damn it
Gary
[Music]
ah
[Music]
this is
dare you be everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is up to 38 of the
askgaryvee show it's windy as hell in
New York I am filming planet of the apps
here in New York City so that's been fun
all day and we found a quick 15 minute
window and I decided to bang out a
call-in show so we're going to get right
into it I'm really enjoying the format
of the show I think a lot of people are
enjoying it what's been going on the
Gary's eShop can put that link up there
I've been asking people to subscribe
subscribe to my YouTube we're doing more
that put that up I'm gonna do a whole
lot of edit on the front yard this
business meeting video is crazy
everybody watching on Facebook live the
next post of this business meeting I did
Andy who is fundamentally numb to my
content because he's been consuming it
24 hours a day for the flat 720 stink
which one is the foot what
just call myself local hey rich Gary's
phone I'm looking for this because who
the hell leave voicemails in 2015 I'm
true here and by god I'm gonna do that
too I'm helping are we good you need me
you need me doesn't need me this just
Trump's you don't need me good all right
learn how to dialed number all right so
the source of these up front answer and
I know a lot of you can excite about but
good weekend football [ __ ] but the
content is rolling the podcast a lot of
associate with it you're going to
Sherman that love he's going to freak
Sherman's good missus big moment
Sherman's good guy hello there is just
Sherman from principled and capable not
even giving the full shout out they're
not being on the phone yes okay good
let's go the next one so while there's
downs have heard that lower while you're
doing I think that uh one of the things
that's really interesting about the
call-in format is the context of going
back and forth to me that's real really
where the value in the last episode came
in and then I'm really excited about
with this one so I'm interested what's
going on Facebook I mean listen you're
out of a job how I work if you're not
capable of like still it all god I won't
even wear someone with somebody who put
in like one two oh nine eight three
wheezy like I was like I just like I'm
gonna figure out that did you're so good
at everything but dialing a phone you've
been crushing every task I'm taking over
I know you guys feed down time so I'm
just going fast that's how we're doing
it
hello Jeremy this is Gary beam you're on
the show Gary totally made my daemon a
bigger fan of yours for so long I'm so
happy he taught me right now I
appreciate a refill Mellie yeah I don't
want a careless Los Angeles awesome man
so what can I help you with yes so um
you know space everything I've learned
from you right I've actually been able
to start building a career for myself as
a social media it's all very nice and
just hoping you know Oh mainly art
actually mainly artists encouraged
companies with their social media
strategy and I've been trying to
transition into not just be the only
person as in my business and building
taller agencies around it in the same
way that you are not in the same waters
but uh so when I'm not the only person
essentially doing the work and I really
struggling on finding the right
instruction point and moment where I can
kind of jump ahead to scale to have a
second person because I'm having a
really hard time making two people
salary on one person's time even with
the fact that I'm working you know is 12
14 hour days to get all discoveries as
opposed to weeks ago yeah I mean look
it's a resource game if you don't have
the money to be able to learn the second
person let me give you a good piece of
ice first of all a mass more money than
you think because any curveball anything
you know everybody wants to get to scale
way too soon it's only predicated on
your finances it's a chicken and egg
game that everybody wants to get to that
second person start scaling and they do
it way too early and they create more
vulnerability people realize once you
have that second person you're managing
somebody else and that drains resources
as well so I would tell you to think in
marathon terms how old your business
like how long have you been trying to do
this as a trend transition for about a
year and a half but is really in a 4-3
or 40 so I mean look it just comes down
to one of two decisions either yep you
save up enough money and you have the
resources to do it and still have your
lifestyle or have you audited your
lifestyle like where do you live I
remember I love you love you yep that's
the perfect answer you might get this
and write and everything so I really
don't have
expenses that stop traveling so they
like I'll be out occasionally so here's
here's your next move charge more yeah
raise everything great raise your
freelance raise your social media
agencies fees charged more do you think
it makes her to charge ahead of the
person or is that just kind of unfair to
charge ahead or a process that would
involve a second person I think that you
need to hustle so I think the answer is
I think you need to deliver on what you
charge people but let's remember the
time is subjective like what if I today
said screw vaynermedia and I'm going to
become a consultant I have a funny
feeling that my hourly fee is more than
yours so you're you're thinking about it
to binary you're thinking about multiple
people 80 hours why don't you just
charged double for your hours right yes
I think that is the problem that I'm
having is essentially what will happen
is all you don't go out sell wat get a
lot of clients and then I'll be stuck
fulfilling those clients and unable
kappa time to keep selling you're not
you're not you're not charging enough
yeah okay Karen and so just are just one
more to one of those issues mainly with
so on is going strategy and kind of
branding strategy and you know hoping
companies and artists communicate their
story of what makes them different
to tutor audience on the difference of
four platforms I've been wanting to all
move into actually social management you
obviously I'm Way more experienced in
doing them and I know that it's a lot
more work do you think there's a certain
point where that'll make more sense that
a certain number of employees because I
know me alone that will probably give
you more of the time and not give me as
value yeah I think I don't think you can
go down that route of putting out
content and doing community management
until you have more infrastructure
because that's much more timely the fact
that you're stretched in on something
that is lofty and theoretical and floaty
as brand strategy means that you're very
far away from the scale that you'll need
for actual execution it's you're selling
ideas right now and conversations when
you have to sell output it becomes a
much more difficult game right okay well
thank you you gotta run hot seriously
I'm 23 and you completely change my life
and relax
for years that I've been following you
and we write a book and real quick for
everybody how so when you say I change
your life has it been more about the
practicality like what is the value prop
yeah I'll give you like a really
specific example my biggest problem was
always discipline right school was
always super easy for me right a lot was
a little and a not engaged with it until
I got to college and had to work super
hard and I started putting 1800 hour
weeks but that was really tough because
I was trying to balance so much and then
after I dropped out I had done work
structured so I really never had any
piece of fun it was something I had to
come by yeah all by myself and work
ethic was always the thing I thought I
was worth debt which is a really bad
thing to be bad as much as I am driven
on the stuff that I really care about
but this year after you know spending a
lot of time consuming your content over
the last year kill for last like five
weeks I'll say I've just been in it
non-stop and I think that work I think
I've been able to develop has been
completely from watching you and the
amount that you're just relentlessly
going at it and so I've been able to
build my discipline build my work ethic
and just be in it every single day
making the most of every day and
actually getting work done rather than
saying oh I can do it tomorrow season
like even a moment if somebody played
I'll just get some work done really
quickly for tweaking you Bruce right you
know waiting for blocks
you basically just did the commercial
for daily basis it's the single reason I
did a levy to eliminate any doubt of the
insanity it actually takes I appreciate
Brett I'm going to move on have a great
day
yeah no worries so sorry he's got a
table what's that Oh captain write to
join is your video yes yes so
nonetheless unknown as well work ethic
ma'am it is the variable that you can
actually be in Georgia Oh Jimmy this is
Gary B and you are on the askgaryvee
show Gary that is awesome man
how you doing guys doing awesome how are
you doing tremendous what can I answer
for you um I have a question about
travel blogging
okay and I was wondering if you could
expand on the Kalitta
kind of like a reason to why I see a lot
of travelogue tons of them you know
around that do their travel blunders and
naming of their blog and they advertise
everything on social network under the
name of the blog and stuff like that
okay would you do a travel blog under
the name of a blog or would you develop
a personal brand within the travel space
I would develop a personal brand within
the travel space because one of the most
important vulnerabilities that people
create for themselves is they niche
themselves in the world as on the
southeast asia guy and then it's four
years later and you want to be the
europe guy where you want to be the
basketball guy building your name is a
much much better way to go look what
happened with me if my twitter handle
was wine guy
i would have had to go through that
branding transition and even without
that just being gary vaynerchuk it was
tough for me to become a business
personality to hundreds of thousands of
people because they had me as a wine guy
i always think you develop your main
because life is long and this is a
forever game right yeah it is
my main reason for asking was because it
was it was more of a niche flood like i
was i was looking at something like like
let's travel america yep and looking at
doing you know and and i about 97% you
know sure that i wanted to focus on US
and domestic travel and stuff so that's
why i was kind of wondering whether to
do it under the name or do it like you
know building build your name or build
your name but builds up the show name -
I have an askgaryvee show and the
Samantha's Gary divas Gary's interceptor
unit this is where people overthink but
I do think your name gives you
flexibility yeah yeah and it's yes it's
it's been it's been bothering me a lot
and I well shouldn't bother you anymore
it's over no more bother good I'm good
man good man it's awesome
no more bothering I mean like you know I
mean why are we pondering on things that
don't matter today's incident post that
I saw a lot of people be emotionally I
was going 1 to 5
Oboro is better and that's a real
thought like radical Michael is scary
here on the askgaryvee show
what up now what is up now is that
you're on because you said I'm ready
with my question so don't [ __ ] me
what's your question my question go my
question is you've posted a plot several
times about the chase but pursue how you
love being on the harping on the game
yep and specifically we relate to
vacation I've got a double date vacation
coming up you've said that you look
forward to getting there but then when
you get there is kind of like an does it
was deliver what you hoped it would be
you you you don't enjoy it as much my
question to you talked a lot about the
work ethic I know you're very
intentional with everything you do so
with the vacation what are you looking
to get out of that what are you looking
to do what's your game plan is you go
into vacation you know I think that the
aunt I think you're taking up in context
to like some comment I probably made in
last couple weeks which is like I
struggle with the relaxing part of it
but my neck neck logically yeah but
you're talking on that you're talking on
medium and my wife we found this issues
I think she believes it to be true of me
as well she said look at this punch from
Gary Vaynerchuk old medium and he's
talking about that when he goes to AJ's
to watch a NFL Draft party he it does it
he doesn't enjoy the being here as much
as he does so looking forward to that
and I feel like that's how you saw that
oh I'm sorry
interested also let's play that out
you're talking about anticipation which
is basically all I've got I think the
reason I'm winning is because I love the
journey and the anticipation more than
destination like by the way I've already
made a video that says buying the New
York Jets is the worst day of my life
because that's the ultimate destination
game I'm playing right yeah like oh I
know you're referring to yeah when I
land a vacation I get sad because it was
the week leading up to vacation because
I love the time with my family and I
loved having that break like I'm already
looking forward to right now I'm already
looking forward to the last two weeks of
August those two weeks in December when
I especially like vacation when the
whole world is shut down because then I
don't feel like anybody's getting ahead
of me you know so I like that
yeah I love anticipation I love the
thrill of the hunt even back to being in
fifth grade I tried to get girls to like
me but then I was so scared of them
because I was too young like I didn't
know what to do at that point but it was
a chase that was fun not the actual
hooking up or having a girlfriend like
that this has been tried and true for me
my entire life you know for example I'm
excited about Vayner sport right now so
much because everybody is under
estimating our agency I'm not going to
like it as much in four years when
Vayner Sports is one of the top sports
agencies Wine Library those days when I
was in I'm a cobra in the leaf it's why
I like negative comments on my my you
know social platforms I like what you do
I want you you want to be able to prove
somebody wrong all right you can yes yes
I love sticking it to your [ __ ] mouth
and I like waiting for things I don't
like in sync ratification yep so for me
personally looking forward to this
vacation here when you are talking about
taking time off intentionally as part of
a rhythm yes what do you what do you do
to get the most value out of that time
away I know I saw you lock the phone in
the in the safe yes and and we don't see
anything up it happens up like and
that's the point but what does that look
like it's just focusing on I'm very good
at one of the things that I get a lot of
compliments for lately that I never
realized is I'm in it when I'm in it
people always talk about like whoa it's
so when you're on dailyvee when you meet
somebody you look them dead in the eye
and you care and this and that and I've
noticed that is something that I use the
outside world to tell me so when I go
into the vacation I know why I'm there
and I want to be there and I lock into
either relaxing or focusing on family
times the end yeah thank you figures I'm
not taking more your time don't worry
followed everyone I unfollowed everyone
on Facebook except for you that was like
that was a very good friend like what
you're amazing that that's very kind
thank you love you thank you
that's pretty good yeah I thought I
think one of the things that was
interesting about that question we're
all water definitely have to know
yourself one of the great things about
loving the game and anticipation is you
don't stop for the short-term fruits
everybody wants the Beamer and the
as a recognition this is Rachel Rachel
this was Gary B and you're on the show
oh god okay awesome I saw the New York
New York number and I did not think it
could be true but it is totally you very
much so it's a very cool well I know
your disease so I will gain support so I
offer the summer started a foster dog
vlog very nice so think of bringing in
rescue dog and I document their stories
which people love because people love
you know the sad stories might
essentially take those cute funny puppy
needs the dog and cat means that you see
on the internet and I put a story behind
them okay I like that though yeah and so
Ln a doctor I said it's super nice right
has nobody else doing that and so within
the first couple months dr. oz actually
reached out with one of his producers
wanted me to come out to the show I
couldn't because they needed me to bring
my foster dogs but we couldn't figure
out a way to do it in the timing that
they needed okay we're still working
we're still working on other things I've
already received local people
sponsorships like all the local pet
stores that huge reach here in Austin
Texas are like we love what you're doing
we want to give you full exposure I've
been on the local news Thank You Craig
thank you where do you think like that
so what's the punchline what can I help
you with so I need your help to IIIi
don't want to say that I want to
monetize right but I need to figure out
what I can do with this and I know that
you probably not know the answer right
away I know the answer I wanted okay I
really do know the answer let's do it
over here and just based on the data and
the energy your head your strategy needs
to be holding your breath okay what I
mean by that is you are going way too
fast to the punchline you need to
foreplay this opportunity okay you're 40
seconds in how long have you been doing
this is month yeah I mean I think I
really think you need to build a bigger
base don't get confused by the exposure
like how many what's your main place
where your set
to a blog it is YouTube how many views
are you getting I don't have about 400
subscribers so I'm about 25,000 views
total so far schools launching getting
[ __ ] right the end so here is happening
your creative is ahead of your reality
okay so milk every opportunity and
continue to get exposure and really wait
and realize that you haven't built
anything that you're actually going to
make money on right the end I'm by the
way I'm giving you tough love because I
love you and I want you to win you're
you're you're getting tricked by a
couple of PR moments in thinking that
you have a scale for anything
monetizable okay so what I would do is
continue use exposure to build out your
base I want you to have more stake
before you worry about how to sell your
sizzle okay
so just continue to get more awareness
just distribute distribute correct nari
correct patience like you're way too
early and I think a lot of people get
confused that hey there's this thing
happening I need to figure out how to
monetize you're going to have short term
results if you're thinking with short
term strategy I would just try to create
more content try to get more exposure
instead of like worrying about how to
make money on this so what how are you
surviving in life you have a job yeah
what I have a 95 great so I just think
that you need to continue on the path of
your 5 to 5 to 6 p.m. to 2 P 2 a.m.
hustle and I know that you want to get
to the place where this is your full
time but I promise you the longer you
can wait the better okay because like
how are you that like let's talk about
it with 400 subscribers and 25,000
overall views like where's the money
coming from that's going to allow you to
like monetize like who's paying well I
think for me my thought is I I don't
know where I want to take it right which
I know is the worst response to have no
no no it's personal it's the truth but
it only speaks to like let's slow down
if you don't know where you're shooting
after to make money then what the hell
are you doing that's exactly right I
love you for that answer but it only
speaks that my advice was even better
than I thought which is you need more
time of doing to maybe figure out the
opportunities in the lane
where you want to play it okay like like
there's no there's no greater
contradiction than hey I want to
monetize this and figure out how and in
parallel I don't know where I'm taking
this okay that's there do you see that
so I think I see I think what you need
to do is did you see episode 130 of
daily be like it's going down in DM like
damming people you saw that or no yes
yes and I do that not that's how I was
able to get the context what I did oh
yes go figure it works
so I much I want you to do more of that
before you focus on anything else I just
want you to build more of a foundation
okay because because if you have a big
foundation then you've got months and
years to monetize because you'll have
time verses oh crap I have to monetize
Mao of that one Hail Mary didn't work
now I got to go back to my nine-to-five
okay yeah that make sense and this is
where I was going but I would cable II
didn't think you'd call so this is
awesome a good boss what that reinforces
it awesome good luck take care thank you
liking you yeah bye-bye I was really
good because that's advice for so many
of you so many people are so excited
other explore their chapter it's like
coming into the NBA draft a year too
early you can add a great career if it
became one year too early you had a
tough working year and kind of
transition you weren't a man yet and you
falter and you didn't have it so many
athletes hello hey Annabel scary be ah
god damn it Gary I know yes it's true
I'm here Ron what can I offer gosh so
exciting hi Gary okay so my question is
my husband and I recently started our
own real estate brokerage in Southern
California loved it and before this
though I was a full-time mom at home
with the girls but so I find myself now
having to split my time part time at
work part time with a girl's heart
so are you recommend for me to do while
I'm at home half of the week meaning for
from your brand got it I think it's
producing content I think it's following
up with leads I think it's a lot of
hand-to-hand combat that you can do
through your phone your phone is your
you know ecosystem and so first of all
when the kids are around like now you
need to be focusing on them that's why
you decided to do it but in every nook
and cranny where there's downtime you
whip out your phone and start creating
content distributing content DMing
people like I talked about in episode
130 all that stuff but here's what I
would say yeah me here's what I would
say you're looking for tactics let's
level it up to religion what you want to
do is first not judge yourself between
you know was today a good day or bad day
take it to macro right and then and then
the tactics are creating content
engaging with people following you know
it could be very not sexting and not
branding what happened during the week
where you guys are talking like
following up with people that have sold
homes to like just good old-fashioned
Thank You economy worth to me did you
leave a Thank You economy I ran off
where about good we read the Thank You
economy that's the first thing I would
do like literally hang up start the
process over a week and every minute to
reread it it's that kind of work because
I think when you're home you could be
doing a lot of harming and reinforcing
the stuff that you created from the
hunting during the rest of the week for
okay so perfect I just real isint to the
Thank You economy two weeks ago good so
no question about Yann tanto from home
would I object there's two parts for
business recruiting agents and in
servicing our agents to help them get
more real estate visit urban homeowners
when you're home service your agents
24/7 365 that's farming okay a period no
hunting no looking for new agents when
you're home because because what I like
about that is first of all the kids
could have a moment pop up when you're
hunting it's a lot better to be
disrupted when you're when you're
farming them when you're hunting because
the farming is all added value I would
be calling these individuals I would be
I would be checking up on them this is
amazing opportunity to farm maybe like
15 minutes yes time yes it's my ESS
three-minute like what look what I'm
doing with you like I tell people all
the time don't ask me for details watch
my actions ID 15 minutes of downtime
right now bang out of mascara TV show I
just gave you please two minutes of
value let's move on perfect good that's
awesome things like so got area ticket I
love you so much thank you
I love them too alright so
no I went very high level they are
farming his retention so they perfect
she walked right into it she's got a
world where she's like maintaining and
helping those agents I like the idea of
using the home time for that because
you're getting value every time where
you're hunting you're suspecting a lot
and you it's just a much harder game
flick it to meet people like there's a
lot of variables she can do the hunting
the farming from her home yes mate how
are you oh you're on the show baby oh
okay so my question is and I think it's
treated you a couple times oh so I'm a
senior in college right now and for me
I'm taking the advice is to kinda like
finishing school could buy one to all
because my parents my grandparents like
any matter straight yep um and all that
um but how do I just like how do I tell
my friends like I just want to go do for
18 months and I've been getting out like
all these of like just go do and explore
so what and why I want you to get the
same job after college and everything
just tell them yeah you're a big boy
it's time okay okay I mean really I
listen look it's easy for me to say
because your dad might punch you in
there out right like I get it yeah but
yeah your looks interesting about a lot
of my advice it's black and white I can
go to your parent there clearly your
signals and your nuances haven't worked
because they continue to want you to go
down that path they are not responding
to you they're responding to what they
grew up with and what they believe
religiously right yeah so so that means
that that means the soft way of like hey
maybe or like like them were like that's
not working right am i right I'm asking
you yeah yeah that's color I keep
getting these like here's and all that
it's time for you to lecture your
parents back okay what are you gonna be
right yeah let me promise you one thing
you really really don't want to be 47
and hate your parents or go because I
promise you you're not actually hitting
your parents you're hating yourself for
not having the balls to do it
go go you want me to come over and have
the talk with you that's very great but
yeah yeah you think you got okay yeah
yeah I'll give them a call right after
you call them right now and Queenie
he'll when Fergus now I'm going to
literally have to sense Chris's and do
it here thing I'm going to have you Bob
are you gonna bother you the rest a day
I want listen while we're like well let
me pump you up a little bit more I will
be your corner manner you start with her
mom and dad I what we're mom or dad
whoever yet I love you I love you burger
yeah I'm 23 years old 22 years old once
I'm done with it I did this for you now
I have to need something for myself
it's high-risk high-reward but when
you're 23 that's what you do because I'm
not going to be able to do this when I'm
47 because it's not going to be
practical it is practical mom and dad
for me for 18 months to just go and do
and discover myself I've been doing the
things for you my whole life it's time
that I do something for me and if you
can't support me in that that's fine I
prefer you do but I've got to do this as
a man okay yeah you don't sound pumped
enough me ah what are you scared of our
talking help me I'm not letting this is
why I'm doing the jerilyn show because
the old show I would have under tweet I
would have answered it I would have felt
great and then you wouldn't have done it
and I could feel like I almost got you
there but I'm telling you right now I
don't think you're going to do it and if
they would do it didn't do it half-ass
they'll help me here while you listen
I'm on your team so help me your
understand what you're scared tell me
how does she okay yeah it's a for me
like like just because like you know
like well pedigree and like Hallett
education and like they've set like
they'd sacrifice like having a fake job
like you or I want like I don't want to
like disappoint affects me hey let me
help you here disappoint for 18 months
and then make them feel good again
burger
I don't just tell them tell them listen
I want me to that means you're
appreciative and you love your parents
tell them the truth
start with that I don't want to like
either your parents love you and will
respond to you or they love you but
they're so deep into structure and it's
been their whole religion their whole
life that they're incapable even though
they love you to break through and see
it a different way the problem is it's
your [ __ ] life and it's going to end
up
one way or the other Wow yeah that's
broke through yeah like like like it's
nothing in there right like you just got
to tell them like I don't know how to
let you down and just remind them it's
only 18 months tell them for the next
[ __ ] 60 years you can do the same
thing that makes them feel great
you need 18 months can they give you 18
months all you want is 18 months yeah
yeah I wrote down the date November 12
2018 that's is [ __ ] [ __ ] contig I
give them it give yourself a few months
and then show them okay are you doing
now yep I'm gonna hang up and call right
now how many understand who is going to
be more critical who only thinks more
who more scared of this meet my mom okay
just go there man just like like just
texting mom I love you with all my heart
I'm so thankful for your sacrifices all
I need is 18 months I can't live with
this regret in my 30s 40s or 50s because
I'm going to crack and I'm gonna be a
broken man I need 18 months and I
promise you if I can't get traction I'll
go wherever the hell you want me to work
yeah yeah that's good uh give them a
call right now and I'll treat you in 20
man give it to me make me a video I want
the video I want to see your face I
don't want the words all right I love
you good luck
do it all right hi Colin show format
gives us so much more opportunity to do
it the right way
tonight all right don't get stuck shut
up no but baby listen don't like
structure he doesn't like to take those
risks give me 18 months done just give
me 80 bucks love you guys question of
the day what is the thing that you fear
the most in conversation format right
now just like that amazing call right
now with me what is the one conversation
that you're most scared to have in the
world do you want to break up with your
boyfriend are you scared of your parents
judging you is it your best friend's
dropping out of school changing jobs
while still having a big college loan or
debt I'm just curious
for the ones that are brave enough to
leave it in the comments on Facebook and
YouTube will that be the liberation by
putting it out big so many you're using
because you're keeping your fears
your poisons inside and literally just
putting it out publicly even with an
anonymous handle on YouTube and
definitely if you're doing in Facebook
maybe that is the unlike in that pipe
that that break in that pipe that opens
up your life I promise when you put out
your fears how loud you win I always
think about this it's the self
deprecation of battle rap right
the reason Eminem wins at the end of a
mile is he puts out all his laundry
which leaves the other guy nothing when
you put out your fear to the world your
insecurities you win you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering
[Music]